yeah welcome to yet another video and
somehow misplace this the some bought a
bit and I went Nadia three let's see d 5
so a queen's gambit oh I let's let's go
g3 going form mmm some ratty type of
setup yeah okay white as I can also take
on d5 but now I'm I want to test this v3
set up this is the traditional classical
way to play this as it was some used by
yeah by Reggie himself of course but
also by an later by an ipod Vinick for
example here white some idea with this
some Queen maneuver is to expand now on
the queenside and gain some space you
also of course have some pressure on
this long diagonal okay so what now c5
not sure c5 doesn't really seem to UM
lead to much yeah maybe maybe still
don't see what else really yeah I can
maybe a plate b6 this was so maybe a tad
too quick those exchanges okay but he
didn't play b6 all right what I'm trying
to do is maybe transfer night to a five
in order to put some pressure against
the bee pollen or maybe the c6 porn
later yeah black softly it has a very
very solid position he can play for
example also night to see seven I didn't
know g7 is hanging so I cannot do that
okay so b6 moon yeah if I play d4 Pierre
has officially fall so I don't really
want to do that ok let's take here i
hope the beep on isn't really a weakness
night a four-night a form i might be an
idea at this is sick spawn the c6 bonus
still a liability here form for black
now probably it's very dry now you can
place you five and down it's just
nothing yeah it's um it's really really
nothing the only thing I can try this
exchange sham crap well it's really draw
but ok I'll I'll play on a bit at least
but of course there's not much happening
can I do that maybe intending Bishop c5
with them something hmm
hmm I did looking a bit shaky actually
night be three can I go nite be three I
mean d falls from me not the ideas i got
if I takes all be three I take on d6 and
then retreat back to before the night on
v3 doesn't have have any good squares ok
so it didn't happen d 494 sand so
nothing ok well let's gain a bit of
space
the only very admittedly minimal
advantages the bishop on h7 large is
really a bit a bit passive I have ideas
would die e-form heh father I need to
prepare your form
check high five like to wait here if
five maybe six or some possible threat
but yeah of course it's a it's a very
draw all this but I wanted to try a bit
but it seems they're there is the
assembly is nothing
maybe I'm overdoing it a bit here it's
possible but this is this is already too
risky but okay what what is he playing
now if you move the light I take G form
takes h3 I take a6 and maybe I have
something hmm hmm maybe I'm getting
getting points here getting the H porn
at least yeah it paid off to I've also
got night h5 g7 and trying to promote
this it's probably just winning now yeah
it is winning now yeah it was very dry
of course but can still can still play
on it so it should be a draw of course
but it's it's always it's a little bit
of something of course black will never
lose this in with normal time but I
think I can play on with less time it's
not done I mean I'm risking to lose on
time with I continuous oh it's okay to
play on a bit I think yeah thanks for
watching